make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this
is rob and we are picking back up again
with uh venom beyond right and this is
basically the start of the king in black
and you guys will see what i'm talking
about once we get towards the end of
this up
this is basically where king and black
begins right so i'm really excited about
this and i think that what we might do
sometime this week as part of a lead up
to the whole king and black thing is we
might take all of donnie kate's venom
run
and just kind of condense it down into a
full story we'll call it like part one
or like the king and black lead up or
something along those lines but
something to indicate this is all the
stuff that you need to know
going into like the king in black but
this basically picks up
again with this alternate reality that
we're in earth1051 whereby you have
dylan this alternate reality version
of eddie i'm sorry this alternate
reality version of the son of eddie
brock
who basically conquered the world and
where matt gargan had been sent to the
forces of eddie for the purpose
of basically taking them down that he
also operates as a kind
of spy of sorts right that dylan can see
through his symbiotes but what we ended
up seeing was that like the previous
video
scorpion was essentially defeated and so
this all kind of coincides with doctor
octopus
showing up to to dylan right codex we'll
call him codex for the sake of keeping
this video simple
instead of talking about two different
versions of dylan but he runs up on
codex and he basically tells him that
they've reverse engineered
the armor that scorpion wore when he was
initially going after eddie brock and
using the name virus and that because
this armor is based on the
war machine mark iii model it was
created by tony stark for james rhodes
it includes
what's basically automated environment
scanning technology which essentially
means that it scans the environment and
then records the environment and this
kind of confirms the statement of of
scorpion to codex when he was initially
captured that he came from an alternate
reality
but what's more important about this is
that when it comes to alternate
realities and marvel comics you have
what's kind of
what's been referred to historically as
a kind of quantum frequency
basically meaning that each individual
universe has its own range more or less
right so the way i like to use it is if
we talked about music
right so we say like the main marvel
universe is the key of c uh and the
ultimate universe might be like he
you know might be like c sharp or
something like that but if the main
marvel universe
is in the key of c then what this means
is that in order to access the main
marvel universe your
quantum signal or or your ability to to
create a portal means you have to
resonate at the key of c
as well right so that's what this suit
basically does this suit will at least
accessing this suit and being able to
reverse engineer it would allow auto
octavius to in effect
recreate a portal that would allow them
to access the main marvel universe and
with his intelligence
it would only take him about two weeks
to do and so the idea is get to work on
it right because it means there'd be
more worlds for dylan to
to conquer essentially at that point you
switch over to uh the underground
laboratory of reed richards in this
alternate reality the crazyreed richards
who's basically kind of talking to
you know scorpion to matt garden and he
really just kind of reiterates
everything that we were already told and
it's kind of nuts because there was an
iron man
in this universe and of course much like
the maine marvel universe reed richards
and iron man were friends meaning that
he's well versed
and and you know starts technology the
problem with this is that he's also
insane and so his response is
yes i can rebuild that game but it'll
take me like five years to do right
it'll take me like five years to do that
because their resources are exceedingly
limited if they had like all the
resources available out there then sure
they'd be able to do it but between his
insanity and the lack of resources they
simply just can't and so you have this
moment here where they talk about the
idea of going back and then the response
of dylan is but i don't want to
the reason why is because dylan never
knew his mom
but he never knew anne wayne and so
being in this alternate reality where he
meets her for the first time it makes
sense he doesn't want to go back
right it makes sense that he doesn't
want to leave anymore that he wants to
stay here he never knew his mom
right and so he's always wanted to get
to know his mom he's now in a situation
where he can why would he want to give
that up it's everything he ever wanted
and so with that being the case it's
almost like he's kind of being forced
right
pulled ripped away from this life that
he wants so dearly and so with that
being the case anne just kind of
realizes that it's turning into a kind
of sentimental moment and anne has still
not gotten over the fact that her son
in this universe this reality's version
of dylan became a bad guy right he
became codex she conquered the world and
killed pretty much everybody she cared
about and turned them into symbiotes and
so she basically like tells everybody
get out right everybody's gotta go
everybody go rest
tomorrow we're taking this award to my
son right now it all kind of comes to a
head
when you've got you know ann doing her
thing because she can't sleep and then
dylan shows up and the two of them have
this very
you know kind of sentimental moment and
the reason for that is because whenever
codex came across her symbiote or tried
to contact her symbiote she would burn
but with dylan from the main marvel
universe that doesn't happen
and the reason for that is because much
like we've seen with like something like
the infinity gauntlet which only works
in its native universe dylan codex can
only control symbiotes in his own
universe and so any symbiont
or any being that's attached to
symbiotes outside of this universe
codex cannot control and that's the
reason why when dylan approaches ann
wayne because he's from the
of the universe he does not affect your
symbiote in the same way he could hug
her
he could interact with her he could
treat her like a mom and that's kind of
what he says
right you know he says like you know
when this is all said and done like i
don't really want to leave i don't
really want to go
but if we do have to go back to my
universe then come with me right like
come with us
be my mom in that universe it's a very
touching moment right this is especially
touching if you know the history of ann
wayne how tragic her story's been over
the years or at least was until they
killed her off
yeah i mean it's it's a very very
intriguing thing to see here
and it's really really cool and so what
this does is kind of you know really
inspire a kind of renewed vigor
inside of ann in the sense that she
realizes she can't run away from who her
son's become
right she can't run away from the fact
that her son has become codex that her
son has done terrible things
it's not necessarily to say that she has
but it's kind of the impression that's
being put off here is that historically
speaking
when it comes to her son codex sure
she's been fighting the good fight but
she's also been dreading the time at
which she would actually have to take
him down in this moment
realizing the the man her son could have
become and if he can be saved the man he
can still become then there's
all the incentive in the world to kind
of leave that fear and that anxiety
behind
and travel head fast into facing off
against this guy and that's exactly what
they do
the other part of this is that codex
comes to the realization of course the
one that we already realized that he
cannot control the symbiotes from
alternate realities either much like
peter parker and venom he also can't
detect them and so that's kind of the
funny thing is that for him whenever he
tries to reach out and detect the the
symbiote of eddie brock the venom
symbiote this attached to him he can't
pick up on it right because it's not
from his universe
and so as they're they're kind of in the
middle of all this and as otto octavius
is continuing to work on this
this you know portal of sorts there's a
kind of an alarm that comes in and it's
basically a
unmanned aircraft that's basically you
know heading towards their location and
when otto octavia says that there's no
life forms on board that's when it dawns
on
on codex no there's life forms there but
it's the venom symbiote right the one
that i can't pick up and this thing
comes cruising in and just boom
smashes right inside the ceiling of this
place right from there and wings like
everybody get in and they all go
flooding into that place right
attacking everybody they can now right
off the bat donnie kate's gives us codex
versus venom and it's a cool thing to
see because this is basically like
spider-man fighting venom right
spider-man cannot detect the venom
symbiote and that's one of the things
that makes venom so deadly for
spider-man much like this here
codex cannot control the venom symbiote
and so he's facing off against a very
powerful person relative to himself
whose symbiote he cannot dominate
and this fight ends incredibly fast
right and that's one of the big
differences here that's kind of the big
weakness of codex is that you would look
at him and you would say okay but a
person who was able to conquer the world
using symbiotes surely he'd be able to
overtake venom but there's a big
difference here
eddie brock has fought time and time
again as venom with the symbiote facing
off against a multitude of enemies the
codex
seemingly has not that i wouldn't go as
far as to say that he rested on his
laurels while the world was being
conquered but there's a difference
between
fighting some heavy hitting superheroes
by yourself and fighting a whole bunch
of heavy-hitting superheroes with
hundreds of symbiotes at your side
it really kind of diminishes what your
accomplishments are it diminishes what
it is that he could actually do because
for the most part
he didn't really do it on his own and so
in response to that he basically calls
in the entirety of the avengers team
they all come pouring in right all the
symbiote avengers guys and then while
that's going on
gargan basically sneaks off grabs his
virus suit and in the moment when you
have eddie brock who seizes control of
codex for the purpose of defeating
him then what he ends up intending to do
is actually have his symbiote
bond itself directly to codex and then
in turn show him this life that he could
have had right a kind of shared memory
but that's when virus makes his attack
right matt gargan shows up at the most
inconvenient time
and starts attacking you know eddie
brock and and basically says like you're
going to take me back to prison once we
get back there and that's not going to
happen
either i'm going to have my vengeance
here or i'm not going to have it at all
but in the midst of his whole attack
suddenly
he shot in the back by reed richards who
would basically use the technology of
tony stark
to take down the war machine suit right
so gargan's you know completely out of
the picture what this does is it leads
to
uh to eddie brock being able to subdue
codex yet again
and then codex actually starts reaching
out directly to uh
to dylan right and what this does is it
allows a kind of shared memory state in
the sense of
it's all the things that dylan can
basically pass through his mother
uh and all the things she can pass
through to him in terms of the life that
he
always wanted to have with her the life
she always wanted to have with him
and then eddie brock's memories of the
life he had with his son bonding them
all together and when that happens
codex gets a vision of what his life
could have looked like they all kind of
do
to be honest like it's really eddie and
his dylan and it's ann wayne
and it's uh it's codex all kind of
experiencing this joint memory
of how life could have been how
fantastic it could have been but because
of the decisions of codex it never
happened that and the fact that eddie
brock took his own life
those never came to fruition and so
because of that codex is completely
overwhelmed by the experience but in
turn
basically gets rid of all the symbiotes
right he just stops his influence over
them and stops and kind of comes back to
his normal self now
the other part of this seems to be that
null had
an exceedingly strong grip on dylan on
codex and so when this whole sort of
shared memory took place it actually
released him from the influence of null
and kind of returned him back to his
normal self but regardless of how you
slice it he's basically back to being a
good guy now the problem is that he
falls into what's essentially a
catatonic state right so you jump
forward by about a year or so and this
is a pretty significant moment that in
all this time that they've been here
you have dylan you have eddie brock and
you have ann who have all just
basically been spending time together as
a family the way that they always
imagine themselves doing this that is
basically a pretty chill world and the
response of all this i mean i'm sure you
probably have some small time criminals
but nothing too crazy
right nothing too outrageous instead
it's basically just them kind of
enjoying their lives and so because of
that there's always kind of looming on
the horizon this idea that they're all
going to have to go back
right that they're going to have to go
back to their universe and so about a
few months after that with dr octopus
having
had the absolute tar beat out of him by
reed to the point that he actually
started giving him information
on how to build this thing that the the
portal is effectively finished but anne
is actually going to stay behind because
with her son you know her son dylan you
know i guess
formerly codex now dylan kind of back
into catatonic state but also
demonstrating
that he basically you know came back to
being a good guy right that he's more or
less
cured for lack of a better word that
she's going to wait until he reawakens
and then try to nurse him back into you
know kind of having a normal life here
but for
for dylan himself and for uh for eddie
of course they go back to the main
marvel universe where the king in black
and everything kicks off and this is
what's really kind of interesting here
it looks like a year has actually passed
in the main marvel universe as well and
the reason why this matters is because
with this one year time jump in that
period
null seems to have come back right no
return he returned in the main marvel
universe and the reason the reason why
we know this is because
when they get back there all the stars
are gone there's
nothing out there but absolute blackness
that null has officially returned and
has already gone the process of
conquering the main marvel universe with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob poor if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you